where we're with the man so we're
already angry and because there's so
much on social media and so much access
to different women at the same time
we're literally winding ourselves up if
you look for it you're gonna find it we
know that and you're responsibility yeah
and exactly and that's what it does it
shows your maturity level and your
um emotional management so you know like
at work if someone pisses you off you
know how to manage it you know you're
not just going to flip out and start
casting because you don't want to lose
your job that's your livelihood but in
this situation you haven't really
calculated how you're going to manage
the situation you've just reacted and I
think as a younger woman like in this
generation we're very reactionary to
what's going on around us rather than
um sorry grounding ourselves first and
then having like a clear fool and and
then responding you know I think I could
actually get older you take a break
realize that though like everyone's
gonna yeah it's always it's a waste of
energy it's literally a waste of energy
I remember being like 14 and finding out
you know someone's cheating and you
would go absolutely mad at them and
you'd cry and you know you'd get really
angry and then as you get older like you
said you'd realize you just you know
yeah if you're gonna do it fine cool
I'll leave you do whatever you want
there's no point in wasting your energy
when you're not gonna get anything back
from anyway because I think women need
to understand that and again I'm not
advocate for it but in most instances
men will be men
so all this angle all this blowing up it
doesn't it doesn't affect no one but you
because like you said
women seem to think that by getting
angry the guy's gonna change or he's
gonna see it differently he's probably
still going to do the same thing just
so it's like is that when when do women
come to the realization that
that's how they're built you're built
different because what and this is what
I've seen before is that there's two
lenses there's your lens and it's the
Mel lens but you're only see things
through your lens so how you perceive
sex is how you think men perceive sex
and it's completely different and what
I'd like to know is after you found out
and you went back how is your behavior
towards him after that it wasn't
you trust him again or was you always
watching him or was down his phone
irritating him always having a dig but I
think that's the end of the relationship
anyway
no point like yeah there's no point
because
well go ahead if there's no point
you know there's no point but you're
continuing relationship I think I think
women that stay it's not because they
want to continue I think it's the
emotions of love and having to like
grieve the relationship while they're
there and I think eventually they get
over it I don't think they go back it's
the one team that they're in you don't
want to you don't want to get rid of the
routine but then also you have women
that will break up with guys in their
head before they've broke up with them
yeah exactly and then when you leave
it's not as hot but in a carrier to that
is that look if if
if we're going to go off the pretense
that most men behave this way and the
men that you're attracted to are in a
small like percentage of men who will do
the same thing anyway doesn't it make
more sense to stay
with the devil that you know than seek
something else new outside
because you know or you can be allow
yourself to feel those feelings a lot of
women
um don't want to feel the pain if you
allow yourself to feel that pain then
you can move through it and pass it when
you sit on it or you go back you have it
there like you're waiting for something
you're anticipating another cheating you
don't feel the pain you're not going to
feel happiness yeah you don't move
through it and I think when one once a
man cheats especially with like social
media and all these things
um we have these experiences and then
we're anticipating something going wrong
and then we kind of provoke it to happen
if we don't work with it like together
as a couple then it's not gonna work
nothing there's no communication in that
I think some women weigh up their wrists
and the rewards because I've I don't
think I'm I always say here that if your
partner cheats on you yeah if you're
going to stay
then you need to be staying to move
forward I don't believe in staying with
someone and every chance you get yeah
why are you here
you make my life miserable but I also
think that there are women as well who
weigh up the realities of life I feel
like with a lot a lot of what a lot of
people think about love it's very um
fairy tale it's very yeah it's wishful
thinking but the realities of life is
that I'm at this age for example we've
been married blah blah blah you've
cheated this is one this is the one time
I've caught you cheating blah blah yeah
what am I going to lose if I walk away
from this
and what's really out there so I think
some some women have to
they just work through it they think
that you know I can't bother to do all
of this again I'm gonna have to find
somebody I'm gonna have to be single
going for a divorce yeah or break up and
then I've spent I have this much time
I've invested so much time in this
relationship you know let's just let me
forget let's forgive it and let's move
forward and do whatever it is that we
need to do to come to understanding that
this can't happen again yeah and I think
I don't I don't see anything wrong with
that stuff
yes if you listen to what they're saying
they actually stay and plan to leave
yeah men just leave women always stay
and plan to leave that's why women get
divorced they lose so much because the
women have been planning it
very few times
get you they cheat and then you actually
get past it and have a happy life what
I'd like to know is I think
I think that people used to get past it
all the time I think modern women can't
because we've been sold a bill of girls
that men can't live up to and we're told
that he has to be taller than us make
money like be basically Prince Charming
and not cheat on you but it's like if
you want a guy on a certain level he's
probably gonna cheat
I think that women romanticize love too
much realistically love is something
that transforms every day when you're
working on it and if you're not working
on it with your partner then it's not
love if you're going to look at love as
a romantic thing for kind gestures every
day your mind's going to be considerate
to you every day it's going to be in
your favor
you have that mentality of entitlement
just because you're in the relationship
and I think from like my experience of
observation men get tired of that
because what's the benefits to them you
know you want more no matter how much
they give It's never enough and then
once they've given the Max Capacity they
can go to somebody else who wants much
less and is happy with that and they're
not going to cause aggravation you find
out about it and then you kick off so it
kind of undoes all the work that's been
put into the relationship on his side
then he loses everything and then like
what's the benefit that's why it should
always be 50 50. so the guy puts in the
energy you know he's being considerate a
fetching the flowers and stuff like that
but then there's no flowers
still do it but then like the girl needs
to give the energy it's about gratitude
it's about gratitude and reciprocity as
well
what have you done
deserve to be courted because we're not
we're not young and we're not pure
anymore yeah I I would say no because
we're not pure anymore like what's pure
yeah
it's all moving forward and forwards
yeah but I definitely think there should
be some level of the basic respect from
that today you know it's not just like
oh we'll text and then we'll meet up and
then like we'll have sex and then that's
kind of it you know you should really
get to know each other and make sure
that you're both on the same level and
if he makes the energy you make the
energy if he doesn't make the energy
just say okay I'll go make the energy
with someone else
that's when the women that got cheated
on how did you feel did you take it
personally
because I think you might have taken it
more personally than he did
but how did it make you feel knowing
that he cheated it is personal it was
with me the problem was I came from a
polygamous household so my dad had two
wives and he's got 14 kids so my mum has
nine my dad had my other mum has five so
I've come from a very
um honest and transparent relationship
the reason I felt disrespected is
because this person obviously didn't
want to tell me even till this day he
would lie right now the reason that I'm
single I'm not actively searching is
because no man is honest and will say to
me actually I am I do want multiple
women because when I asked them they
will just say no I'm cool and if they
did say like if they said it I'll
respect it because 100 way more but you
know what you have to remember in this
situation you're the exception to the
rule because women often fall in love
what they hear not a mental level that's
the thing I think I'm still quite a
traditional woman so I I don't I haven't
done the dating scene traditional women
get married before the age of 25. I was
married I am well that's my traditional
women don't get divorced well you can't
be you can't be a traditional no no I'm
I'm not divorced yet so I'm not divorced
yet so no [ __ ] I thought you said you
were single no well I'm it's complicated
so I'm not divorced yet okay I'm
separated but obviously the reason why I
like
um like Esther said the reason why I'm
not pushing for the divorce or whatever
is because in within my situation I'm
weighing out what's beneficial to me if
it's better for me to stay or better for
me to be ending up in the streets and in
the Streets of London it's not for me
it's the ghetto girls
why do you want to leave because it was
he the one that cheated no no so this
with my within my marriage what happened
is we were a lot younger and because I
was conforming to like just say the
Western ideologies and social media yeah
put a big pressure on what I expected
from the relationship so I wanted like
you said flowers and all of this and
blah blah and I put importance on that
instead of me actually looking and
growing with the person and you know
figuring out our own lives and we were a
lot younger he obviously wasn't where he
wanted to be and I think it just put a
lot of strain on us so we have separated
but it for me
give it I probably will end up back with
him just because it's it wasn't a toxic
relationship it was a good relationship
we just weren't the right people so do
you think women by that women leave nice
guys because you stayed with the guy who
cheated but the guy who didn't stay with
the guy who cheated because I didn't
know for sure okay